[Music]
on tv
on radio and on your smartphone this is
talk tv
[Music]
i'm pissed morgan on sensor tonight a
prime time exclusive they were the
shocking comments that stunned the world
billionaire formula one founder bernie
ecclestone defending vladimir putin
i'd still take a bullet for him
i'd rather didn't hurt but a movie that
i still take a bullet
because he's a first-class person
and
what he's doing is something that he
believed was the right thing he was
doing for russia
tonight one of the most controversial
men in world sport responds to the
scandal that's rippled across the world
after those words bernie ecclestone goes
one-on-one with me in an explosive
jaw-dropping interview in which he
attempts to explain what he said and why
he said it
[Music]
[Music]
well good evening welcome to piersmorgan
uncensored tonight a gripping incendiary
interview with one of the most powerful
figures in the history of world sport
formula one founder bernie ecclestone
this weekend should have been about the
british grand prix at silverstone one of
the most prestigious events of the year
and the sport that he created instead
this weekend's racing has been eclipsed
by two explosive scandals centered
around one person him
first it emerged a former world champion
nelson piquet had racially abused
british superstar lewis hamilton
branding in the n-word several times in
a podcast pk has now apologized but
denied the term he used was racist
even though it was racist
well astonishingly in an interview with
my old tv show good morning britain this
morning bernie eggleston defended pk
and then in comments which sparked a
global ferrari he then defended russian
dictator vladimir putin
tonight on uncensored and a prime time
exclusive bernie eagleton responds to
all the heat
when you say you don't think vladimir
putin meant to wage this war it just
sounds to me shockingly naive at best
i'm not trying to defend him in any
shape or form why would you say that you
would still take a bullet for vladimir
putin it's an expression when did you
last speak to him i'm not going to
answer that you're defending nelson pk
for calling him the n word which you say
should be treated like somebody calling
you a bit undersized it's terribly rude
to say somebody's underscore i'm always
a fat person you genuinely think that
there is some equivalence between
calling a black person the m word and
saying that you're short if for example
they're black and they're saying or if
you're fat i suppose it's the same sort
of appealing it's not though is it what
is your response to what lewis hamilton
said bernie complete load of rubbish
that's no surprise to me bernie your
comments this morning calls outrage and
i think when people watch our interview
they're going to feel more outraged
you're trying to set me up
um which you're not successful in doing
well ecclestone's longer running formula
one but his comments matter he wields
massive global influence people around
the world pay attention to what he says
and after this interview i suspect
they'll be paying a lot more attention
he's had the whole day to reflect on the
comments he made about president putin
this morning and about lewis hamilton
being called the n-word i started by
asking if you stood by what he said
about the russian dictator
well i'm joined now by bernie ecclestone
bernie uh good evening to you
good evening to you
buddy i've known you a long time uh
you've never been one to hide your
thoughts you've always been a straight
talker but now you've had a few hours to
see how your comments about vladimir
putin and about nelson piquet and his
racist comments how they played out in
the public arena do you have any regrets
what i meant just wonder whether you
whether you regret the way you worded
some of the things you said
i forgot what i said actually
well okay i'll remind you you said that
whatever i said i meant
so
good or bad
well
let me remind you what you said so you
said about vladimir putin i would i
would still take a bullet for him i'd
rather it didn't hurt but i would still
take a bullet because he's a first-class
person and what is what he's doing is
something he believed was the right
thing
yeah i mean when i say i take a bullet i
mean i'm quite sure it's an expression
you couldn't have used
uh in your life
it's an expression
i'd stand behind it
i mean the problem with the thing
yeah sorry go on buddy
no he's a he's a
as far as i'm concerned he's a good guy
he's never done anything that i would
feel
he's not the right guy to be talking to
i mean you're perfectly entitled to your
view about putin from the dealings
you've had with him and obviously you
started the russian grand prix and i
understand that and you've had a lot of
dealings with him you're perfectly
entitled to that i think the problem
that people have with your comments
today bernie is that they are highly
inflammatory given that putin is
currently waging a monstrous illegal war
in ukraine slaughtering thousands of
innocent people who are literally
getting a bullet from vladimir putin
and i think that's terrible
i think when all this started it wasn't
what he thought was going to happen i
think he thought it was going to be a
four day sort of threat and then
big discussions and they get things
sorted out
i don't think he believed
what is happening would happen i think
the problem that people have bernie is
that you're entitled to your personal
opinion about it but when you say
as you just did you don't think vladimir
putin meant to wage this war it just
sounds to me shockingly naive at best
and i can understand why many people are
offended you're not you're not a stupid
man
but you know everyone can see what putin
has done here he's invaded a sovereign
country a democratic sovereign country
he's carried on now waging this war for
months and months he's slaughtered
thousands of innocent mothers children
people in ukraine uh only two days ago
he attacked a supermarket with a
thousand civilians inside it
the idea that this is something he
didn't really mean to do i think is for
the birds
well i wonder if i don't i'm not trying
to defend him in any shape or form
because what's actually happened
is quite terrible
simple as that should have never ever
ever happened and i think if
people that have thought about it a
friend from the ukraine and him and
thought that or met and discussed it it
wouldn't have happened because he's not
an idiot
and he wouldn't have gone into this
expecting what's happened i think he
thought he'd sort of move in
and then there'd be a discussion when
they saw how strong it was
i mean again i would say to you bernie
all the evidence suggests bernie that he
has planned this meticulously for a very
long time all his activity in crimea in
georgia previously it's all been leading
up to this he wants to restore the power
of the soviet union and he doesn't care
what it takes to do it and he's he's
basically waging a genocide in ukraine
and that's why people found your
comments i think this morning on good
morning britain so
so tone deaf and defensive
well i think if i was listening to
myself in the way you've sort of
put things i would feel the same
but i
if he plan to do this i think it's
disgusting and i'm very disappointed in
him
why why would you say given what we've
been seeing happening in ukraine why
would you say that you would still take
a bullet for vladimir putin given that
he's putting bullets into thousands of
innocent people's heads
that is an expression i'd take a bullet
for somebody you may not stand behind
him
for what he what he was i
genuinely
i don't know what he had in mind
i hope he
also
didn't have in mind what's actually
happened
and i'd be surprised if he did
i honestly believe he sort of marched in
there thinking it's going to be a
surrender
white flag was going to go up and that
was it
but bernie he has no right to do that he
has no right to invade a democratic
sovereign country this is a european
country ukraine it is with a sovereign
it's a sovereign democratic countries or
somewhere you can just invade because
you feel like it
i don't think you sort of felt like it
did it i mean have america moved into
different countries where they're not
really welcome
well we could play what about hurry as
you know i was one of the people that
led the campaign against the iraq war
for that very reason so we can talk
about other countries i think what
people have been shocked by today bernie
is they've seen you come up on
television
and at a time when putin is is
at his most murderous and barbaric in a
bombing supermarkets you you appear on
television and act as his defender as
his supporter to the extent that you
would take a bullet for him and whatever
you meant by that phrase i think it's
called it's caused huge offense i just
wonder whether on reflection
you wish you hadn't been quite so
supportive maybe you do maybe you don't
regret it but
i don't regret
my feeling for him
that he's not the person that is being
portrayed
in fact in fairness nobody's portraying
him at all they're just showing up up
exactly what is happening and saying
he's the one that's made it happen
well i mean you also go on to attack uh
president zielenski
who use you sort of sneer at him saying
he used to be a comedian i think he
wants to continue that profession as a
comedian what has been comedic about
zolensky's leadership if you know all
he's done is try to stand up for his
country and his people there's nothing
comedic about it is that
well this way he's been acting i mean
i think he's uh he's looking for a bit
of publicity whereas nobody had ever
heard of him before and now he's talking
to the president the united states and
everybody else
and not just talking to them making sure
he's speaking to them when he's been
televised and broadcast worldwide but
you genuinely think zolensky is doing
all this for self publicity
i don't think he's doing it for so
obviously i was doing it because he
doesn't have his choice the only choice
he had
was before it started but to try to
contact
putin and have a discussion with him
why should he do that he's the leader of
a democratic country he's elected
president
in a democracy why should he have to
call a dictator in russia to try and
ward off his troops why should he do
that
well before the troops went in he could
have done that
and i suppose if he knew what he was
going to happen
that would have been the right thing to
do wouldn't it
no i don't think it would have been the
right thing to do is to stand up for
your sovereign democratic country and
your people i think zielinski's shown
unbelievable inspiring leadership what
he said is no you will not invade us you
will not destroy our cities you will not
raise them to the ground with your
bombers you will not attack our
supermarkets our mothers our children
our maternity units and he stood there
in the middle of it he hasn't left the
country which many leaders could have
done in his position he stood there and
he's fought with his people i can't
think of a more outstanding example of
heroic courageous leadership frankly
that's what you think
yeah it is what i think
that's how you've seen it
i don't understand why you would see it
any other way bernie
but simply he could have stopped himself
couldn't he
i think if i wanted
this to happen i was there
and i wanted to protect my people i'd
have
got hold of putin and said listen we've
got to stop this
and what would you have done surrendered
i'd have found a very dignified way to
do that because that's in fact probably
what will have to happen anyway
what is the dignified way to to end this
then
to end this
they should talk to each other
what about
about what's happening
well we know what's happened putin's
invaded ukraine and has started killing
every ukrainian he can find i mean
what's there to talk about if you're the
president of ukraine
what do you talk about with vladimir
putin other than telling him get your
tanks off my lawn
maybe that would be a good start
well he he keeps saying this in public
zilenski he's made it very clear he
wants russia to stop attacking his
people which seems to me a pretty
reasonable thing for a president of
ukraine to say right now
he said on television here
well what's the difference peter knows
pretty knows what he's doing
a little bit different if you're talking
face to face with somebody he said no
listen let's stop all this nonsense
a lot of people are being killed because
of this let's stop it
well coming up he says putin's a good
guy and you take a bullet for him but
how close is the formula former formula
one boss to the russian tyrant i'll ask
him that next when did you last speak to
him i'm not going to answer that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to bismarck and i've
censored a prime time exclusive
billionaire formula one founder bernie
ecclestone we've heard we just said
about russian tyrant vladimir putin that
he's apparently a good guy and he'd even
take a bullet for him so how does he
feel about him as a person when did he
last speak to him
you said about putin that you you trust
him that he always delivers on his word
is that is that what you think of him
yeah
when did you last speak to him
i'm not going to answer that
but was it was it during the war
in the war
i haven't spoken to him since his
conflict started right
and if you did speak to him what would
you say to him now
i wouldn't be able to give him any
instructions and i wouldn't want to i'd
simply say have you given the love of
any thought to exactly what's happening
from when you
invade it if that's the right word what
to say
ukraine
i mean he's saying he didn't invade it
and he's in this military operation
you know that's complete nonsense bernie
don't you
he obviously invaded ukraine we all saw
it we've seen him he's seen what he's
done
i'm saying that's what he says
why would you again it comes back to why
would you believe that then you seem to
believe everything he said it's like why
his actions clearly speak to the
complete opposite of what he's saying
did you hear me say i believed it
you said that you trust him and you and
you take him at his word did i say i
believe
i believed it
do you believe him
no
okay so you don't believe all right well
that that that's progress i think about
this you don't believe him when he says
that it was an operation you do believe
he he waged war deliberately
no i don't think he weighs forward
deliberately
but i think he threatened
and used his
troops
on the borders to threaten
that they should start talking
bernie as somebody who's a grandfather a
father
you know and i know you're a loving
family man
when you see
children
being
blown to pieces when you see maternity
units with pregnant mothers being
deliberately attacked when you see
refugees being targeted as they try and
flee when you see millions of people
losing their homes having to leave the
country when you see all this
does not a part of you think i got it
wrong about putin actually
he is a monster
i don't think i'd say i actually
remember the last war and i'm sure you
did as well
these things happened there
when england was sort of moralistic
wanted to be invaded
these things happen in war
it's not a nice thing to happen and you
know
as well as anybody else in the end after
a war everyone's good friends it's like
a boxing match after the boxing match
everybody's loving each other
i don't think there's much chance that
people do i don't think there's much
chance bernie are people being good
friends with vladimir putin after this
the entire international community is
now pretty much
agreed with the exception of some of his
allies that what he's done is completely
reprehensible and flies in the face of
of all international law
how many uh rations were there in
ukraine when he had
invaded well they're not the ukrainians
some of them speak russian but they're
they're ukrainians
they were russians well they're not
though they're ukrainians
they were all russian people that just
yeah now you're sounding like you're
sounding like putin bernie in the sense
of what putin wants to do he wants to
restore the soviet union and pretend it
was never broken up and these countries
didn't go off and become democratic
countries but that's what they did you
can't undo it it'd be like the british
empire suddenly being restored and just
assuming that history is irrelevant and
that countries haven't moved on haven't
become independent
that is a very nice way to put it the
way you put it it's probably the truth
and i'm quite sure
if you asked him
he would say what has happened was a
mistake
yeah but it's more than just a mistake
it's a mistake that costs as cost an
unbelievable amount of
innocent lives being taken
not only innocent lives assuming
captured completely ukraine what has he
captured
a country that's been destroyed
right so it seems to me bernie you
understand what's really going on here
and that makes your stoic defensive pl
putin right now so baffling to people
you know you're one of the most powerful
figures in world sport in my lifetime
you have huge influence stuff that you
say
carries enormous weight
as you can see from the reaction to what
you said i just find it completely
baffling that you would think this is
the right moment to say vladimir putin
is a first-class person
as far as i'm concerned he was
right so is he now
i'm a little disappointed in
the actions that have been taken
now what's what's the what was the
alternative either he pulls out or the
other people surrender
well actually the alternative is you
don't invade sovereign countries
illegally and kill everybody and to say
you're a little disappointed by a
murderous genocidal rampage again your
use of language bernie is is
extraordinary a little disappointed that
he's murdering innocent people every
single day all day long
now i'm disappointed in what
has happened
because i would have never believed it
would happen under his feeling
could it be that vladimir putin has
pulled the wool over your eyes bernie
he's not the person you thought he was
that she's not this mr trustworthy guy
that actually he's a duplicitous
dictator and now we're seeing the
absolute reality of what putin's about
well i suppose looking at what's
happened
you could sum it up in that way
so if that is the if that is the case
and you can see that is the case
why would you still take a bullet for
him
there was an expression i said i would
it started it wasn't something i said
today for the first time no i know you
said it before you said before you stand
in front of a machine gun
for vladimir putin and when you said
that that was before the ukraine war i
think what's upset people so much is he
saying it today
when we're months and months into this
war and the
the slaughter of misery has been
unrelenting to the ukrainian people and
there's you bernie eccleston one of the
most famous figures in world sport
basically giving an emphatic endorsement
to vladimir putin saying he's a
first-class person you completely trust
him and you take a bullet for him you
must understand why that's caused such
offence
what uh i'm saying i'm saying what i
believe
nothing to do with any sport
or anything that i represent this is my
personal feeling
about putin
not a feeling many will share i'm sure
coming up more of my prime time
exclusive interview with the formula
formula one boss bernie ecclestone
including shocking comments about the
n-word attacks on lewis hamilton in
which eccleston says well it's like
someone saying he is too short
you genuinely think that there is some
equivalence between calling a black
person the m word
and saying that you're short for example
well if for example they're black and
they're saying or if you're fat i
suppose it's the same type of feeling
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk tv
[Music]
well welcome back formula one mogul
bernie ecclestone made headlines around
the world today by defending russian
dictator vladimir putin and we just
heard him pretty much double down on
that but he also shockingly defended
former world champion nelson piquet for
racially abusing lewis hamilton the
british superstar driver calling in the
n word twice in a podcast will hamilton
today dismiss them both as irrelevant
old men
the the other thing that you said today
which caused a lot of upset to people
was he defended nelson piquet the former
formula one uh legendary driver who used
the n-word in a podcast to talk about
lewis hamilton in a derogatory way
and i want to display you what lewis
hamilton has said about this and in
relation to your comments
we should not be giving
these people a platform
these old voices are you know whether
they're subconscious or consciously
do not agree that people like me for
example should be in a sport like this
do not agree women should be here like
it's just
discrimination is not something we
should be projecting and promoting
and given a platform to create and
divide people
you know we're all the same and
it is not helpful
the comments that we're seeing from
these people and i don't think you know
the last couple weeks i don't think the
day's gone by where there's not been
someone from
uh some of the older
uh that have not really been in our
sport or relevant in that sport for
decades
trying to saying negative things and
trying to bring me down but i'm still
here i'm still standing strong
what is your response to what lewis
hamilton said bernie
complete load of rubbish
really
really
why would you say that
because nobody's i don't if he's
referring to me
it's nothing i've done he should even
think a little bit
his father and myself were talking about
going into business a little while ago
i've got nothing in the world to do or
not i'm not
racist quite the opposite actually
and to say things are there is
completely crazy
you say that but you've defended nelson
pk for using the n-word to describe
hamilton personally in a derogatory way
it's hard to imagine a more racist thing
for somebody to do than what pk did and
yet you defended him he said people say
things
if people happen to be a bit a little
bit overweight or undersized like me i'm
quite sure people have made remarks
about that
i'm surprised lewis hasn't brushed it
aside or better than that replied but
now he's come out and nelson's apology
why should lewis hamilton brush aside a
formula one legendary figure like nelson
piquet calling him the n word
well i didn't i don't know what the n
word was
well the m word's the m word it's not
ambiguous
well i don't know what it was i i mean i
didn't know
did he said something in portuguese i
believe he used the brazilian equivalent
of the m word but it's exactly the same
in its connotation it is exactly the
same and it's racist intent he made a
racist comment that is why everybody
uh right now is distancing themselves
from pk apart from again you
and you know in the same interview that
you've defended putin who's waging an
illegal war you defend nelson pique for
calling lewis hamilton a disgusting
racist epithet
and and and then when lewis hamilton
responds in the way that he did which
most people completely understand you
call it absolute nonsense
not that he never mentioned bk
or the n-word
did he
yeah but
how can you defend nelson pk for calling
lewis hamilton the m word
and how can you dismiss what lewis
hamilton says is nonsense when he's
clearly as
the only main black driver in formula
one why on earth why on earth would you
not have any empathy for him about
having to be called this
now stop a second
the question
to him i don't know his answer wasn't
about the n word
the answer was about
elderly people being involved in the
sport been able to speak
he said we met i gave
a
a colored driver first
informal one and the guy came out
very clearly
and was very thankful
recently said this
i pulled things out of south africa
i've probably done as much for anybody
about racist which i'm
anti-anti-anti
i can honestly say i've said it before
i've never met
a colored person
that i felt i don't like see even the
language you're using now bernie will be
uh inflammatory to people
because you talk about people of color
or black people but they don't use that
phrase colored people i mean lewis
hamilton's response to that would be
you've got to move with the times and
use the language that is less
inflammatory do you understand that
which is what
good for example which is used you
either say that they are a black person
or people of color that's the language
that is used today
well i said that
you said colored people
yeah what color
how can i word it maybe my english isn't
good but i would have thought people
would understand that it's not ambiguous
bernie what he said
he used a word which is the brazilian
equivalent of the n-word there's no
doubt about this it's all on a podcast
everybody's heard what he said
yeah they all understood it i'll brush
up on my portuguese
and probably all the people that heard
it would do have to do the same
lewis hamilton also said an interview
with the telegraph in relation to your
comments about putin
he said you know what you're going to
get with that i don't know where good
morning britain's uh goal was this was
great and and divide by having you on as
a guest at all
he said we don't need any more of it to
hear from someone that believes in the
war on the displacement displacement of
people and killing of people and
supporting that person putin is beyond
me i cannot believe i heard that this is
going to put us back decades and we've
yet to see the real brunt of the pain
why we do not need to be supporting that
but looking into the future you don't
have anything positive contribute don't
give them any space so lewis hamilton
was enraged that you were even given the
platform to say that you supported putin
but in relation to what he says about we
don't need to hear from someone that
believes in the war what do you say to
that
i'm surprised i mean sorry
what you showed me just now was
something that
that
lewis had said this is an interview
given to a telegraph today uh in
relation to your comments nobody said
that because you've recorded it and
you're explaining it to me where was it
says no no this is these are further
quotes from lewis to the telegraph
they're not on camera so this is an
interview given to the telegraph
what you said shown me was him talking
and speaking that that was saying yes
that was earlier this is other quotes he
said to the telegraph
but wait a minute that's what he said
how did he get that platform to say that
and why should he have been given the
platform to say that
so you don't think lewis hamilton should
get a platform to respond to what you
said
yeah i'm delighted you did i'm
what i can't understand is why he
complained that i had a platform
to say something well because you don't
because you're defending uh a war monger
vladimir putin who's waging an illegal
war and because you're defending nelson
piquet for calling him the n-word which
you say should be treated like somebody
calling you a bit undersized
yeah
exactly which happens all the time
there is no equivalence between somebody
calling a black person the n word and
saying that you
are undersized there's no equivalence
you must see that
terribly rude
sorry
it's terribly rude to say somebody's
underscore always a fat person you
genuinely think that there is some
equivalence between calling a black
person the m word and call and saying
that you're short for example
well if for example they're black and
they're saying or a pure fat i suppose
it's the same sort of feeling
it's not though is it
i don't know it depends if you're fat
you genuinely think that people
commenting on someone's size
has the same ability for offense as
commenting on somebody's skin color in a
derogatory way
yes
why not
well i've said so next reaction to my
essential exclusive interview with
formula one mogul bernie eggston that's
the pierce pack coming next
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to peterborough in our
center lots of reaction coming in
already to this extraordinary interview
with formula one mogul bernie ecclestone
we've just seen him rebuke lewis
hamilton about the audacity to be upset
about being called the n-word well now
it's the final part of my interview and
then i'll get reaction to the interview
with my peers back tonight i gave my
last opportunity to explain himself or
even express regret
it's no surprise to me bernie your
comments this morning calls outrage and
i think when people watch our interview
they're going to feel more outraged
because they're going to think you just
don't get it
well my feelings of putin have only been
my meetings with him
and things i've done with him
so that's my feelings about him that's
what i think he's a straightforward guy
but he's been straightforward as far as
i'm concerned
and he's done everything he said he'd do
so from that to me that's good
because there's not many people
around today that like
as for nelson i've known nelson for
years and i'm very surprised that he
would be
saying something
bad
that he really genuinely believed and i
think he might have exploded
over the accident with
lewis and
max verstappen well there's never any
justification for anybody saying the
n-word and even less justification
frankly for someone who's a big figure
in the formula one to say it about the
most famous black formula one driver is
is it's a disgusting thing that pk said
and what you should have done if you
don't mind me offering some advice to
someone of your venerable age and
experience what you should have done
when you were asked about it is simply
condemn it and say absolutely outrageous
anyone would say that about lewis
hamilton but he said you didn't you
defended it and likened it to someone
commenting on someone's size
and that's why lewis hamilton was so so
upset and outraged
if any if i heard anybody
in front of me say that
to lewis i would defend lewis without
any shadow of death but you didn't
defend him when you when you were when
you were told nelson pika you were
booked on the show good morning britain
specifically to talk about what nelson
pique said so you knew what he said and
you defended him i don't know that word
defended on i don't understand that
what do you mean let me explain what i
mean by defending when you were asked
about it you said that uh people say
things if people happen to be a little
bit overweight or undersized like me i'm
quite sure a lot of people have made
remarks about that i'm surprised lewis
hasn't brushed it aside
i mean yeah why should he brush it aside
lewis hamilton doesn't think we should
even be giving you platform to say this
stuff i don't happen to believe in no
platforming people i want you to be able
to clarify and explain what you said but
the fact you still don't really get
why it would be so offensive
to not condemn what pk said is what will
baffle people
but it wouldn't be offensive to me if
anyone said anything
in that way about me i would defend it
but you say that you're not racist and
you say if you heard someone say the n
word in front of you you would tackle
them and yet when you're told that
someone you know nelson pk says this
about lewis hamilton you go on national
television in the uk to defend him
and i can't swear i can't square those
things what would it take bernie for you
to
denounce vladimir putin and cut off any
association with him what more would he
have to do
what would he have to do yeah
well i've not spoken to him as i said
during this conflict went on
so i don't know
if my relationship with him
will still continue
why would you want it to him what he's
done
i'd like to
which i would obviously if i wanted to
have the answer from him as to why he
actually acted in this way bernie i
appreciate you coming on the show i do
uh you didn't need to i appreciate you
giving more clarity to your comments
this morning i'll be straight with you
like you're saying only a long time i
was startled by what you said this
morning
i don't think i don't think you should
be
defending putin in any way and i think
you should be roundly condemning nelson
piquet everybody else has done and i
think you know if i were you i would
look at the comments
on every single news story about this
which have been published and see what
the public feel about what you said and
you might be surprised maybe you're not
interested maybe you don't care but
there's been universal condemnation for
what you said
no i do care and i've had a few phone
calls
saying to me well done pity a few more
people don't speak like that you've had
people say well done because you
defended vladimir putin
and you defended nelson pinkey
well the world down on the on the show
really you you've had people
congratulating you on what you said this
morning
hang on just comment dear bernie just
saw your interview about russia loved it
what did they love about it
margaret asked i just read what was on
the
come up on the phone
so just to just to end bernie you've got
no regrets about what you said
i regret perhaps the way
people have tried to sort of twist
around to make me look as if i've done
something wrong
i don't think anyone's twisted your
words bernie
honestly when you when you say things
like
putin's a first-class person i'd take
your bullet for him no one no one needs
to twist those words they speak for
themselves i am very very very
disappointed in what's happened
with the people in ukraine
and i'm in the process now of putting
something together
to fund
the fact
of the poor people that have suffered
and to the people of ukraine who were
outraged by what you said
including president zielenski what would
you say to them
i haven't spoken to the other people
but what would your best speak to them
now in this interview
if they're watching i'm terribly
terribly terribly sorry what happened
okay bernie ecclestone thank you very
much indeed for joining me i appreciate
it
thank good thank you
extraordinary interview well we have
some breaking news just come in uh quite
extraordinary story that the
conservative deputy chief whip
christopher pincher has resigned tonight
after apparently going to a private
members conservative club last night and
groping two men his letter to the prime
minister boris johnson sort of admits it
all really says dear prime minister last
night i drank far too much i've
embarrassed myself and other people
which is the last thing i want to do for
that i apologize to you and those
concerned he's not quite deputy chief
whip this of course could prompt him
having to resign as an mp which would
mean another violation so another blow
to boris johnson and his conservative
party uh the odd thing about this story
is that christopher pincher has had to
resign before
uh for groping another man uh seems to
be something he does quite regularly and
then he had to resign that time for the
whips office i would just suggest to
borrow johnson maybe don't have him back
in the whips office any time soon anyway
he will be now to react to the bonnie
nicholson interview and this breaking
news are tonight's pierce pack
conservative writer esther kraken
feminist author and playwright bonnie
greer welcome to both of you we'll get
to mr pinscher in a moment uh happily
named a character i would have thought
mr pincher was up to you
quick reaction though to bernie
ecclestone on two points bonnie one his
extraordinary defense of vladimir putin
who he calls a good guy i take a bullet
for him even his sort of torturous
explanation for why he felt this way
such an offensive thing to say at this
time and then he defends nelson piquet
for calling uh lewis hamilton the n-word
which i found almost as reprehensible
well let's do like it let me take three
quick things first of all it's great
that you pushed him it's not enough to
it's not good enough to say he's on he's
91 years old i know 91 year olds they
you know that's not an excuse the guy
has always had his own way he's had he's
built the world the way he wants
uh putin is a war criminal he's even
kind of admitted it so it's not
acceptable people let him go because oh
bernie ecclestone's 91 uh-uh that's not
it the other thing is pk needs to be
suspended right at least he obviously
traumatized lewis hamilton you can tell
by the way he responded this has
happened to sir lewis since he was a
little boy by the way what makes it even
worse is that nelson piquet's daughter
is the current partner apparently of max
verstappen who is lewis hamilton's
number one rival in formula one well
this guy needs to be gone first of all
you know with dust behind him and
everything else um uh lewis hamilton sir
lewis hamilton is probably the greatest
british player of the person sport in a
long time so that's not acceptable it's
not normal and it shouldn't be like
great esther i mean i just found that
lewis hamilton's argument today was that
there are these old guys in the sport he
means nelson pk he means uh uh bernie
ecclestone he also means something to
jackie stewart he's being critical of
him as well he says that these guys
should just now quietly go away because
the sport is trying to move on away from
this kind of mindset i don't think
bernie eggerson did himself any favors
in that interview with me trying to
explain himself even the language he
used about colored people and so on yeah
it sounded so kind of dickensian and
it's amazing that that was his
trying to sort of make amends by using
being polite enough to say colored
people you know i think what lewis
hamilton is trying to explain to these
people that don't understand is the
culture of the sport has just been you
have to have wealthy parents to be able
to even be in that sport to get to the
level to be what one of twelve people
that are good enough to do which makes
his achievement all the greater
extraordinary it's like tiger woods in
golf
and i think that's what he doesn't
understand because he doesn't understand
the culture wrong he doesn't even
understand how difficult it is to get to
his level like that's why i don't think
he even has the kind of respect that he
should have for someone like lewis
hamilton right i agree you don't even
defend what that man said i think the
deeper thing and i agree with you 100
is what sir lewis said these old people
just need to go right i mean the the the
sport
i have one problem with that which is i
don't think he should just say old
people shouldn't well well
these specific old people who are
espousing views which are clearly well
he said something that he had to say was
coming out of him i don't think it's the
age
right what he did mean is you know he
says about women about people of other
abilities
they don't need to be in that sport
anymore they need to retire themselves
and i'm glad you did this because again
i want to stress this it's not okay
because bernie ecclestone is 91 years
old well i was allowed to get involved
right i've been in a long time bernie
sanders and i know his family very nice
family and i he's always been
provocative but i watched the interview
this morning on good morning britain i
was like
you've got to go after him about this
you've got to hold him accountable and
try and get inside his mindset about
what's going on esther i want to move
quickly just to christopher pincher
before we run out of time so this guy i
mean i suppose because we don't really
know who this guy is until these stories
break it's a big story because it's a
sun exclusive tonight um and a good
scoop by then another blow to boris
johnson another sleazy story the guy has
fallen on his sword yeah possibly
literally we haven't got the full gory
details uh but he's gone um this may
trigger another violation another
problem in heaven
and they will lose there is rot in the
tory party and it doesn't make it any
better the fact that the head of the
tory party is quite literally the
embodiment of and they will lose the
problem with the tory party is these
kind of people because that you know
if you want to become a sort of a
conservative mp the selection post is
not open so they literally have these
type of people that are funneled up the
party system and they breed they they
maintain this culture what you just said
is absolutely the point there's a man at
the top and this atmosphere is over i
agree the moment i read a letter a
resignation starting dear prime minister
last night i drank far too much yeah i'm
reminded of the fact that 86 of boris's
staff at number 10 got fined from the
police the party games
they all drink too much that's the
problem ladies i'm going to leave you
there thank you for being so patient
tonight uh the interview ran long as we
know but it was great to have both of
you in your perspective uh so i
appreciate that well that's it from
tonight extraordinary interview with
bernie ecclestone i don't know if he has
improved or worsened his position from
this morning i suspect from what i'm
reading on twitter right now he's made
things slightly worse by digging an even
bigger hole
attitudes have to change my sympathy and
all this is with sir lewis hamilton who
has come so far and in such tough
conditions in a sport that was
exclusively white
and he deserves to be treated with more
respect than he's currently getting
that's it for me tonight whatever you're
doing keep it uncensored goodnight
[Music]
this is talk tv news
good evening i'm emily rose adams the
deputy chief whip of the conservatives
has resigned after allegedly groping two
men while drunk last night chris pincher
told the prime minister that he'd
embarrassed himself and others he
intends to stay on as the mp for
tamworth a fourteen-year-old boy who
helped murder his five-year-old
stepbrother has been stripped of his
anonymity by a judge craig mulligan will
spend at least 15 years behind bars for
killing logan mawangi and bridge end
last summer victim's mother and
stepfather have been jailed for life too
and former formula one boss bernie
ecclestone has doubled down on comments
supporting vladimir putin the 91 year
old told piers morgan that the russian
president is a good guy and had no
alternative but to invade ukraine
that's all for now we'll have more news
updates after the talk
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you